[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بحصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتطور اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم على
واقع حاله ترقب بعد اعلان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تقيدها التام ببرود الاتفاق
الايطالي
ثم الى مدينه جنيف السويسريه التي شهدت
اجتماعا لتنفيذ اتفاق تبادل الاسرى بين
ممثلين عن الحكومه اليمنيه وجماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين
ثم الى تبليسي في جورجيا واجواء حذره بعد
يوم من الغاء برلماني جورجيا قانون تصنيف
العملاء الاجانب المثير للجدل
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
على وقع سجلات ليبيه ليبيه بشان تنظيم
الانتخابات المبعوث الاممي يطرح مبادره
لاجراءها قبل نهايه العام ويقول ان
استمرار الوضع المؤقت للسلطه التنفيذيه
والهيئات التشريعيه عرض البلد للخطر
يرحب ويدعو للانخراط في جهود انهاء
المرحله الانتقاليه ورئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله يشدد على اجراء الانتخابات عبر
القوانين اللازمه لذلك والمبعوث الامريكي
يدعو القوى السياسيه للتوصل لحل يكسر
الجمود السياسي
بعد تصاعد الخلاف العلني بين البرهان
وحميته بشان الاتفاق الايطالي بيان للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه يؤكد تقيدها الصارم
ببنود الاتفاق وبالمضي قدما في العمليه
السياسيه القوه المدنيه الموقعه على
الاتفاق ترحب والقوى الرافضه تدعو الجيش
للوقوف على مسافه واحده من كل التنظيمات
السياسيه
من على خط القتال الغربي باخذ الجزيره
ترصد اشتداد وتيره القصف المتبادل بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
ميليشيا فاجنر تعلن اقترابها من مركز
المدينه استراتيجيه وقياده الجيش
الاوكراني تدفع بتعزيزات اليها وتتحضر
لهجوم مضاد ومع احتدام المعارك بوريل يقول
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يستنفذ خياراته
المتعلقه بالعقوبات ضد روسيا
موجه احتجاجيه جديده رفضا لتعديل نظام
التقاعد في فرنسا
المتظاهرون يعودون الى الشارع في باريس
ومدن اخرى قبل يوم من انتهاء مهله
المناقشات البرلمانيه لمشروع القانون
الجديد ماكرون يتمسك بالتعديل والنقابات
تدعوه الى تنظيم استشاره شعبيه وتتمسك
بالتصعيد
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم طرحه رئيس
بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا عبد
الله بتيلي مبادره لاجراء الانتخابات قال
ان الهدف منها هو جمع الاطراف الليبيه
وتجاوز حاله الركود الحاليه لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما مدى فرص نجاح
المبادره الامميه في حاله في حل حاله
الازمه الليبيه وقد جاءت النتيجه على
النحو التالي
14% اعتبروا ان الفرص كبيره بينما قال 33%
ان الفرصه محدوده وراى 53% انه لا توجد
فرصه لاطلاق اطلاقا لنجاح المبادره
الامميه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت مع عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
يتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وكذلك دوليا
[موسيقى]
مقالات وتشابات الازمه في جورجيا بعد سحب
مشروع قانون يثير للجدل حول تصنيف
المنظمات غير الحكوميه عملاء اجانب
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي عن مبادرته لاجراء
الانتخابات وقال انها ستعطي الشرعيه
لمؤسسات البلاد وتهدف الى جمع الاطراف
الليبيه وتجاوز حاله الركود بوضع خريطه
الطريق للانتخابات بحلول منتصف شهر يونيو
القادم وقد رحب رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه بالمبادره
ونشد الليبيين التحلي بالاراده لانهاء
المراحل الانتقاليه عبر انتخابات عادله
ونزيهه من جهاته قال رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله خالد المشري ان هناك اراده سياسيه
قويه لاجراء الانتخابات عبر القوانين
اللازمه لذلك
حوار ليبي الليبي يجمع اطراف الازمه في
البلاد لتجاوز حاله الركود والانسداد
السياسي الحالي هذا هو الهدف الرئيسي من
مبادره مبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي لاجراء الانتخابات نهايه هذا العام
من خلال خريطه طريق تكون جاهزه مع حلول
منتصف يونيو حزيران القادم
تتمثل هذه المبادره في تشكيل ما سماها
باتيل لجنه رفيعه المستوى تختارها اطراف
الازمه الليبيه بما فيها مجلس النواب
والاعلى للدوله ولا دخل للامم المتحده في
تشكيلها تقود التفاوض مباشره بين اطراف
الازمه او من خلال ممثلي هذه الاطراف في
اللجنه
ان الفريق رفيع المستوى على النحو الذي
قدمته لكم لا علاقه له باي حل المفروض من
الخارج ولا يتجاوز الاطراف او المؤسسات
الليبيه بل يشملهم جميعا كما شدد باتيلي
على ضروره اطلاق حوارات بين الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه في كافه انحاء البلاد
للاتفاق على ضمان امن الانتخابات توالت
ردود الفعل المحليه على مبادره باتيلي
فرئيس الحكومه راها متسقه مع مواقف سابقه
قال فيها ان عدم اجراء الانتخابات سببه ما
وصفه بقصور الجهات التشريعيه عن ايجاد
قوانين قاب للتنفيذ وعادله ونزيهه كنا
نتمنى اليوم في هذا اللقاء الصحفي ان تكون
مبادره واضحه المعالم واضحه الجداول ولكن
اليوم عندما تحدث وقال مجلس لاعلى الدوله
ومجلس النواب يعني قال تلتحق مؤخرا احسن
من لا تلتحق اعتقد ان هذه مؤشرات صراحه
الى ما زال الوضع كما هو عليه في الوقت
الراهب تهدف مهمه المبعوث الاممي الى
ليبيا لانهاء المسارات المتعثره للازمه
الليبيه بانتخابات نهايه هذا العام وتلك
مهمه لا شك ستواجه بتحديات عده ابرزها
مواقف الاطراف المحليه المدعومه من دول
اقليميه عرفت بلعب ادوار رئيسيه في تطورات
الازمه منذ سنوات
احمد خليفه الجزيره من داخل مقر البعثه
الامميه في ليبيا طرابلس
الى ليبيا ريتشارد نولاند قال في تغريده
على تويتر قال انه بحث يحث الاطراف
السياسيه الليبيه على الاستماع الى
ملاحظات المبعوث الاموي والنظر في كيفيه
ان يكونوا جزءا من حل يكسر الجمود
السياسيه
مع المساعي الامميه القائمه باينت مواقف
ورؤى اطراف المشهد الليبي للوصول الى حل
سياسي وشكل الجدل المصاحب للقاعده
الدستوريه التي تحدد شروط تنظيم
الانتخابات وطبيعه مؤسسات الحكم المقبله
نقطه بارزه في خلافاتها من هي هذه الاطراف
وما ابرز ما تطرحه من مواقف وحلول نتابعه
في هذا التقرير
في ليبيا تمت افتراق بين مختلف اطراف
المشهد السياسي بشان ما يعرف بالقاعده
الدستوريه التي تحدد معالم وضوابط
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه المقبله
يمكن اجمال هذه الاطراف في المجلس الاعلى
للدوله الذي راسه خالد المشري هو مجلس
النواب برئاسه عقيل صالح وحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه برئاسه عبد الحميد الدبيبه
وفعاليه سياسيه مختلفه يتطور المشهد تحت
اعين جهتين داخليه هي المجلس الرئاسي الذي
يقود الحكم حاليا في ليبيا ويعتبر نفسه
محيدا وبعثه امميه لليبيا يراسها السنغالي
عبد الله بطيلي في ظل انقسام الليبي اصدر
مجلس النواب ما عرف بالتعديل الثالث عشر
للاعلان الدستوري رسم التعديل المعلن نظام
الحكم في ليبيا بتشكيل سلطه تشريعيه تتكون
من غرفتين وسلطه تنفيذيه يراسها رئيس
المنتخب من الشعب ويكلف رئيسا للوزراء
اللافته هو ان التعديل لم يتضمن اي اشاره
الى شروط ترشح رئيس الدوله المثيره الجدل
محيلا ذلك على قوانين انتخابيه يفترض ان
تصاع بالتوافق في لجنه مشتركه من مجلس اي
النواب والاعلى للدوله مجلس الدوله وبعد
مسار متعثر وانقسام داخلي بين اعضائه صوت
على التعديل الدستوري وان قال رئيسه انه
لن يتنازل عن موقفه بضروره منع مزدوج
الجنسيه والعسكريين واعضاء السلك القضائي
من المشاركه في الانتخابات في حين يرفض
مجلس النواب وضع هذه الشروط فيما يبدو
لترك الباب مفتوحا امام ترشيح خليفه حفتر
بالموازات اعتبر رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبيبه ان اي قاعده
دستوريه يجب ان تطرح للاستفتاء امام الشعب
الليبي وانه لا عوده للحكم العسكري مجددا
لليبيا اقرار هذا التعديل الدستوري وفقد
بيبا لا يتوافق مع ما اقترحه باتيلي على
مجلس الامن الدولي بتشكيل لجنه وصفها
بالتوجيهيه تتولى صياغه خريطه طريق
للانتخابات هذا العام قوى سياسيه ايضا
رفضت التعديل ون بهت لما سمته مخاطر
الانزلاق المستمر في مسار التنازلات
والاخلال بالتوازن المطلوب في التوافق
الوطني توافق يبدو ايضا غائبا بشان من
ينظم الانتخابات فالمجلس الاعلى للدوله
ومجلس النواب يطالبان بحكومه مصغره وموحده
لتنظيم الانتخابات بينما يؤكد دبيبه ان
حكومته اكثر قوه اليوم فلتعبير عن اراده
الليبيين لانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه
وتنظيم الانتخابات المقبله
معنا منا طرابلس المحلله السياسي الليبيا
الدكتور مبروك الجمبري اهلا بك دكتور
مبروك كيف وجدت هذه المبادره
ولهجه التفاؤل لدى السيد عبد الله باتيلي
بالحديث عن امكانيه اجراء انتخابات نهايه
هذا العام هل جرت مياه جديده تجعل هذا
المستوى من التفاؤل واقعيا
هذه المبادره على فكره هذه المبادره
مبادره ضعيفه جدا مقابل المبادله عيلتها
زمان بتاع الخمسه وسبعين لجنه الخمسه
وسبعين بكل ما فيها من سيئات كانت عندها
من الصلاحيات والقوه والقدره انها تمشي
الامان للاسف الشديد كان عندها قوه قدره
انها تحول الاسماء المعقلين واخد في
مقارنه الامن كان عندها القدره اذا كان لم
يتفق مجلس الدوله مجلس الاعلى في الوصول
الى قاعده دستوريه العمليه من خلال
علاقاتها مع الاوساط القانونيه في ليبيا
كان عندها القدره تتجاوز هذه الاجسام
للاسف الشديد نجحت في نصف الطريق ولكن
للاسف الشديد لم تصطفل تكمل الطريق لاسباب
نحو
مبروك
كما ذكرت ان الشيطان في التفاصيل ام
الاطار العام الذي قدمه السيد عبد الله
باتيلي لم ياتي بجديد
اعتقد انه لم ياتي بجديد لان في سؤال طرح
للاستاذ عبد الله البتيلي في اللقاء قال
ما هي المعارقلين وانتم عندكم القوانين
التي تدعم معاقبه القوانين وتحويل اساميهم
الى مجلس الامن لم يجب على هذا السؤال
وللامانه عبد الله بتيلي اطرح مبادره بشكل
عام
من خلال صندوق الانتقام
هذا اكبر هذه مغالطه حقيقيه هذه مغالطه
حقيقيه نحن تماما انه المؤسسات والكائنات
اغلبها في ليبيا الاغلب نتاعها راهي عندها
سلطه محدوده داخليه ولكن التاثير الخارجي
ودول متدخله في شان الليبي هي المسيطره
دكتور مبروك باشارتك للبعد الخارجي حتى مع
التحرك الاخير ل واشنطن وجمعها لجمل
الاطراف الدوليه الفاعله والمؤثره في
المشهد الليبي ودعوتها الاطراف الليبيه
الى العمل من اجل القيام بهذه الخطوه ودعم
ما يقوم به المبعوث الاممي تراها بانها لا
تحضر اي تغيير
صعب جدا لان لعند هذه اللحظه الدول
المتدخله قاعد لعند الان لم تتفق على
الوضع الليبي في داخل على سبيل المثال
عندك الان روسيا روسيا الان خارج الصف
الموحد الاوروبي مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي الان فاعل على الارض وهناك
دول ايضا وظيفيه اخرى تتبع روسيا في هذا
المسار وبالتالي اي اتفاق داخلي بالوصول
الانتخابات وصول النتيجه لا يمكن ان يتم
الا عن طريق اتفاق هذه دول عظمى وروسيا
عبرت عن هذا تماما اعتقد امس او حتى اليوم
عبرت عنه ان لا يمكن الوصول الى حاله الا
باتفاق شامل وكامل الليبين بمعنى ان
الاطراف التي مع الطرف هذا او ذاك اذا ما
كان عندهاش اشاره واضحه من الجهه الداعمه
من مخالفه اللي يمكن يصير حدث النقطه
المهمه الاخرى في الاتفاق او في المبادره
للاسف الشديد السيد عبدالله دخل قصه بعض
الشخصيات اللي هم رؤساء القبائل واعتقد ان
هذه سابقه خطيره جدا انا اعتقد شخصيا لانه
عندهم مهمه مهمه جدا وساميه في حل المشاكل
الاجتماعيه جانب السياسي في هذا الموضوع
ضيفنا من طرابلس المحلل السياسي الليبيا
دكتور مبروك القنبري شكرا جزيلا لكن نبقى
في ذات الملف هذه المره من واشنطن الدكتور
اندرو
المسؤول السابق في الامم المتحده لشؤون فض
النزاعات في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
والخبير بما هذه السلام الامريكي لشؤون
شمال افريقيا دكتور اندرويد اذا
السيد باتيلي ياتي بمبادره تحمل شيء من
الامل بانه بالامكان اذا ما قامت اطراف
الليبيه ببعض الخطوات الوصول في نهايه هذه
السنه الى اجراء انتخابات بين واقعيه هذا
الطرف وبين المعوقات في الارض كيف ترى هذه
المبادره
جزيلا على الاستفاضه
استضافه وكما هو الحال معكم ضيفكم الاخر
انا اثمن سعاده المبعوث الخاص باتيلي على
خطته هو يقول كل الاشياء الصحيحه التي
ينبغي ان تقال خاصه نقطتين
دعمه ومقترحه بانشاء اللجنه توجيهيه
لتنظيم الانتخابات قبل نهايه العام ثانيا
العمل مع مجموعه خمسه زائد خمسه اللجنه
العسكريه وهو يعمل مع اللجنه الفرعيه التي
تتعلق بنزع السلاح واعاده
الدمج الميليشيات وما الى ذلك هو ايضا
يعمل مع
الاتحاد الافريقي ومع الهيئات العليا مثل
هذه الجهود تحتاج الى دعم المجتمع الدولي
بالطبع
المستمع الدولي ايضا للنقل الواقع من واقع
الدوله الى واقع محلي ناجح لكن كما نرى ان
هناك بواعث امنيه عرقله الكثير من الامور
وعدا عن
بعض الامني هناك البعض العسكري بين دبيبه
وحفتر البعض الايمن طبعا يحتاج الى دعم
لكي نضمن ان الانتخابات تكون سلميه
وجامعه للكل هذا يحتاج الى دعم الكل يجب
ان يدعم الدكتور بتالي لتوفير انتخابات
امنه ثانيا فيما يتعلق
باللجنه الانتخابات طبعا يجب ان يتم تعديل
وتحديث اللوائح والقاعده
دعني دعني اركز معك على اشارتك للمجتمع
الدولي كيف وجدت تحرك واشنطن
الاخير بدعوتها لدعم جهود سيدي عبد الله
باتيلي وكذلك
بلقائها كل بكل هذه الاطراف الدوليه من
اجل المساهمه في الوصول الى هذه النتيجه
هل هذا التحرك من قبل واشنطن كفيل بان
يحدث تغييرا حقيقيا في ليبيا
انا افهم ان اللقاء هنا في واشنطن مع
مبعوثين من عده بلدان في العالم
مشى بشكل جيد كان هناك دعم موحد وهناك نوع
من الدعم على وساع الناطق للدكتور
باتيلي قبل انعقاد مجلس الامن اذا هناك
توافق في المجتمع الدولي بالنسبه لاطراف
مؤتمر برلين ما زال هؤلاء فاعلين خاصه في
على النطاق الاقتصادي وهناك عمليه وسيروره
مستمر انا اعتقد ان المانيا تدعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتعب هذا المبادره واشنطن اذا
هناك الكثير من الدعم لاستعاده السيد
بتيلي من واشنطن الدكتور اندرو المسؤول
السابق في الامم المتحده لشؤون فض
النزاعات في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا والخبير بمحد السلام الامريكي
لشؤون شمال افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى شان اخر حيث اكد الناطق الرسمي باسم
القوات المسلحه السودانيه العميد نبيل عبد
الله التزام الجيش وقيادته بالاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يوحد المنظومه العسكريه
ويشكل حكومه مدنيه ورحبت القوه الموقعه
على اتفاق الايطالي ببيان الجيش ووصفته
بالايجابيه بينما جددت الكتله الديمقراطيه
رفضها له
بلغه متشدده اصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا
اكد فيه التزامه صارمه والتامه بالاتفاق
للطريق لاكمال العمليه السياسيه في
السودان البيان جاء بعد تصريحات مختلفه
تشكك في التزام قاده الجيش بالعمليه
السياسيه تؤكد قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه
الموقعون على الاتفاق الايطالي رحبوا
ببيان الجيش ووصفوه بالايجابي وقالوا انه
يدفع باتجاه تحقيق التحول الديمقراطي
ويحفز الاطراف المختلفه على تجاوز
خلافاتها بشان الفتره الانتقاليه البيان
وجد ترحيب من قوى الاطار ترحيب باعتبار ان
هذا موقف محدد ومصرم العبارات
شهدت الايام المنصرمه تباين في وجهات
النظر بين قياده الدعم السريع وقياده
الجيش ولكن هذا البيان اكد ان هناك ليس
هنالك خلاف حول الموقف من العمليه
السياسيه وهو ماشي باننا سنصل الى اتفاق
نهائي قريب لكن الكتله الديمقراطيه التي
تضم عددا من الاحزاب وحركات مسلحه جددت
رفضها الاتفاق الايطالي ودعت الجيش الى
الوقوف على مسافه واحده من كل التنظيمات
السياسيه يبقى الحل في التوافق على اعلان
او اتفاق سياسي جديد تكون كل الاطراف
الفاعله في فتره الانتقال اعضاء في انتاج
هذا الاتفاق بلا استثناء ياتي البيان وسط
تبين في المواقف بين قائد الجيش البرهان
ونائبه قائد قوات الدعم السريع
بشان كيفيه المضي قدما بالعمليه السياسيه
خصوصا ما يتعلق بدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش اضافه الى احتدام الخلافات بين
المكونات المدنيه حول معايير مشاركه القوى
المدنيه في ترتيبات الفتره الانتقاليه
بيان الجيش السوداني الداعم للاتفاق
الايطاليه ربما يحرك جنود العمليه
السياسيه ويسرع خطوات اتفاق ينهي ازمه
باتت تهدد امن واستقرار البلاد بسبب
انتقال الخلافات الى داخل المكون العسكري
الطاهر المرضي الجزيره الخرطوم
ارحب بضيفيه من الخرطوم سيد محمد ادم
القيادي بالحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه وكذلك بضيف من الخرطومه
اللواء معتصم الحسن الاستاذ السابق في
الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم وابدا بضيفي السيد
محمد ادم لاساله عن
ما الذي جاء في هذا البيان بيان الجيش
وماذا عن توقيته بالنسبه لكم
نعم في البدايه التحيه لكم
والتحيه ايضا للمتابعين للحصاد على قناه
الجزيره انا في تقديري انه البيان الذي
صدر من المؤسسه العسكريه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه اليوم على لسان ناطقها الرسمي
هو موقف انا لا اعتقد انه فيه نوع من
الموقف الجديد بل هو امتداد لموقف وضعته
المؤسسه العسكريه تجاه دعمها للاتفاق
الايطالي ونحن جلسنا مع المؤسسه العسكريه
بمفردنا ككتله ديمقراطيه وايضا جلسنا
ككتلتين مختلفتين على الوضعيه الاتفاق
الاطاري في المرحله الانتقاليه لمجلس
المركز الحريه والتغيير والكتله
الديمقراطيه لحضور المكونه العسكري بطرفيه
كل جلسه على حده واعتقد انه نحن كان راينا
واضح جدا في الكتله الديمقراطي انه نحن
لسنا ضد العمليه السياسيه في السودان نحن
نرى ان منهجيه التي ادرت وضعت بها الات
الايطالي من حيث كثير من النقاط المختلفه
التي نحن اوردناها في بريد المجلس المركزي
وكذلك في بريد القوات المسلحه السوداني او
قياده الجيش وتحفظاتنا معلومه للجميع
بالضروره من خلال طيله فتره حديثنا عبر
المؤسسات الاعلاميه المختلفه من ضمنها
مؤسسه الجزيره فنعتقد انه هذا الموقف هو
ليس موقف جديد لكن
هل كانت جيش تحتاج الى هذا البيان لتاكيد
هذا الموقف وموقفها معلوم
والله انا في اعتقد انه هذا هذا البيان
الذي صدر من المؤسسه العسكريه هو يجاوب
على
خطوه حقيقيه يمكن حدثت في الايام الماضيات
وهو اختلاف القوى العسكريه على على
الاتفاق الايطالي من حيث المنهجيه التي
تحدثنا عنها في تقدير انه الخلاف داخل
المكون العسكري انا بالامس كنت على قناه
الجزيره مباشر وتحدثت بانه اذا لم تتفق
المكونات العسكريه مع بعضها البعض تجاه
الرايه الواضح والمحدد تجاه الاتفاق بعد
ذلك يدار حوار ما بين المؤسسه المدنيه
بشقيها المجلس المركزي والكتله
الديموغرافيه ثم بعد ذلك يتم حوار شامل ما
بين المكونات المدنيه والمكونات العسكريه
في كيفيه خلاقه وتشكيل اتفاقي
معتصم الحسن فيما يتعلق بما ذكرته الان
ما مدى وجاهت ما يثار ان بعد البيان هناك
ترقب ربما لقرارات تتعلق
بمجلس السياده بذاته
لك التحيه والشكر الجزيره والتحيه لضيفك
الكريم والتحيه للساده المتابعين
اولا انا اعتقد ان البيان جاء في توقيت
لان هنالك كانت كثير من التصريحات وقد
حواها البيان هنالك كانت محاولات
لضرب العلاقه ما بين المجلس الانتقالي او
المكون العسكري وما بين قوى الاتفاق
الايطالي هنالك جهات كانت تحاول ان تستميل
القوه الموقعه للاتفاق الايطالي وادعاء ان
القوات المسلحه نكثت بعهدها وبالتالي يجب
ان تميل القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي الى جانب المكون
الدعم السريع فكانت هذه احد
المسائل في الفتره السابقه كذلك كانت
هنالك محاوله للادعاء بان هنالك خلاف ما
بين قياده الجيش وما
قواعد القوات المسلحه السودانيه كان هنالك
البعض يقول انه لا خلاف لهم مع القوات
المسلحه ولكن خلافهم مع الذين على راس
القوات المسلحه والذين
يتمسكون بالسلطه ولا يريدون تحويلها الى
المدنيين
هل تستبعد مساله ما يثار عن امكانيه حل
هذا الاطار مجلس الدوله وتعويضه بقياده
عليا للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه بتراتبيه في المسؤوليه بشكل
معين كما يثار في الشارع السوداني هل
تستعد هذه المساله ماذا
انا اعتقد كانت هذه من الاطروحات التي
طرحت في اربعه يوليو الماضي ولكن
يوجد في الساحه الان اصرار القوات المسلحه
على ضروره على ضروره ان تكون قوات الدعم
السريع
منها والا تمارس اي عمل سياسي خارج اطار
المنظومه العسكريه ومن بعد ذلك دمج قوات
الحركات المسلحه توحيد الجيش السوداني
اولا وفقا للاطار
للاتفاق الايطالي ومن بعد ذلك النظر في
بقيه القضايا هذا هذه المساله لا تتنافى
مع العمليه السياسيه ان تنضم الكتله
الديمقراطيه الى الاتفاق الايطالي او ان
ياتي اتفاق جديد ان يناقش محتوى الاتفاق
الاطاري او يوسع الاتفاق الايطالي هذه
عمليه سياسيه اكد عليها البيان في البدايه
في البدايه البيان اكد على التزامني
بمساله هذه المزارع للخطوبه اللواء
المعتصم الحسن الاستاذ السابق الاكاديميه
العليا للدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من الخرطوم ايضا محمد
ادم القيادي بالحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتحديدا
المعركه المحتدمه للسيطره على مدينه باق
موت اكد رئيس ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه
ان قوته صارت على بعد نحو 1200 متر من
مبنى اداره مدينه ضخمه
عند ذلك المبنى المؤلف من خمسه طوابق حيث
يتصاعد الدخان يوجد مبنى اداره المدينه
وسط باخموت يبعد مسافه 1200 متر تقريبا من
هنا وفي هذا الاتجاه سيحاول الاوكرانيون
القيام بهجوم معاكس من الشمال بالنسبه لنا
من المهم ان يقدم لنا دعم ناري لحمايه
الاطراف وان لم يحدث فسنصبح محاصرين وسط
بخموت
ومن جانبه قال قائد القوات الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه العقيد الكسندر سيروسكي ان من
الضروري كسب الوقت في بخموت لتكديس
الاحتياطات وبدء الهجوم المضاد في الربيع
واضاف على صفحه القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
في فيسبوك
ما زالت تحت سيطره قواته وقال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بالقوات والمعدات لمنع
سيطره روسيا على باخموت واجبار مقاتلها
على التخلي عن تقدمهم
هذا وقد تعرض الموقع الذي كان يوجد به
فريق الجزيره لقصف مدفعي عنيف اثناء
تغذيته تصاعد الاحداث في غرب باغموت ورصد
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود لحظات القصف على
الطريق الفرعي الواصل بين كريستيان ايفركا
سمعنا قبل قليل
صوت قذيفه فوقنا لا نعلم اذا كانت من
اتجاهنا من الاتجاه الاخر
[موسيقى]
محاولات القوات الروسيه محاصره في مقاطعه
تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه الحفاظ على
سيطرتها على الجهه الغربيه من المدينه
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود ايضا رصد الوضع
في التقرير التالي
دون توقف يسارع الاوكرانيون الى تعزيز
قوتهم الناريه
والاستعداد لاي هجوم محتمل نحو الجهه
الوحيده المتبقيه بيدهم والمؤديه الى
المدينه المتواليه خلفت الكابتلال
نرافق وحده من المظليين اثناء تجهيزها
مضاد الدروع الاوكرانيه المطوره حديثا هذا
لمواجهه الاليات الروسيه في حال تقدمها
نحوهم
سلاح فعال ضد الدبابات نراقب اهدافنا عبر
هذه الشاشه ونصيبها عن بعد حوالي خمسه
كيلومترات ونستطيع التحكم بالصاروخ
وتوجيهه
افراد الوحده الذين شاركوا في عدد من
معارك جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا يرون في باخموت
واحده من اصعب المعارك لكنها تلحق خسائر
بشريه وماديه كبيره بالقوات المهاجمه كما
يقولون تظهر هذه اللقطات التي خصتها
الوحده بالجزيره تدميرهم احدى الاليات
الروسيه على اطراف بخموت
[موسيقى]
يحاولون ان ياتوا الى الجهه الغربيه ويقطع
طريق كوستانتينيفكاباخمت لكننا مستعد ون
لمنعهم وضرب دباباتهم
تكتيكاتهم العسكريه تشمل الدفاع عن بلدات
ومدن ما بعد ضخمه في حال وقوع الاسوء
بالنسبه اليهم عبر هذه الوسائل وغيرها
يحاول الاوكرانيون الحفاظ على سيطرتهم على
الجهه الغربيه لمدينه ومنع تقدم القوات
الروسيه اليها ومحاصره المدينه بالكامل في
ظل قرار القياده الاوكرانيه مواصله القتال
هناك
عبر بلده تشاسفيار يتواصل زحف الدبابات
كما المدرعات المحليه والغربيه نحو
المعركه المتواصله منذ اكثر من ثمانيه
اشهر فالبلده باتت اشبه بمعسكر للقوات
الاوكرانيه وممرضا لمدافعها حيث لا يهدا
القصف منها كما عليها
ورغم خطوره الاوضاع ما زال بعض السكان
يعيشون هنا
اصطحبتنا لوبول الى منزلها الواقعي عند خط
النار وكان الحال يحكي عن نفسه
الا تشعران بالخوف لبقائكما هنا
بالطبع نشعر بالخوف صحيح اننا نشعر بالخوف
لكننا مضطران للتعايش مع الوباء
بضع مئات اثر البقاء في البلده رغم الخطر
الشديد وباتوا يعيشون على مساعدات
المتطوعين املين الا يتدهور الوضع اكثر
لكي لا تلقى بلدتهم مصيرا مشابها لمصير
جارتها وان تصمد قواتهم هناك لالا تسقط
رايتهم هنا حسن مسعود الجزيره غرب بخموت
في تصريح لافت اكد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل اكد ان
الاتحاد يقترب من استنفاذ كافه الخيارات
بشان فرض العقوبات على روسيا وقال بوريل
بعد اجتماع لوزراء دفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي
في ستوكهولم ان الاتحاد استخدم كافه
الاوراق لديه بتدرج وربما بشيء اكثر من
التدرج لافتا الى ان على الاتحاد الان
يركز اهتمامه الى على التحول الى تقديم
الدعم المالي والعسكري لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا خرجت مظاهرات النقابيه في باريس
ومدن عده احتجاجا على مشروع قانون لتعديل
نظام التقاعد وهذا هو سابع يوم من
التحركات المستمره منذ يناير ضد هذا
التعديل وقد اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي تمسكه
بالمشروع فيما دعا الامين العام لاتحاد
العمل احدى اكبر النقابات الفرنسيه
لاستفتاء بشان القانون
اعمل اعمل لا تتوقف
[موسيقى]
ومن يريد ذلك في ظروف الفرنسيين هذه
غليانهم الاجتماعي ذو المسحه السياسيه
حركه مشروع لاصلاح نظام التقاعد صحيح ان
سن التقاعد في فرنسا هو من بين الادنى بين
سائر الدول الاوروبيه لكن التعديل الجديد
بدل الفرنسيين في عمومهم ظالما خصوصا
للنساء والعاملين في الوظائف الشاقه اذ
يرفع تدريجيا سن التقاعد القانوني من 62
عاما الى 64
لم ترى النقابات العماليه بدا من التصعيد
بعد اربعه ايام من مظاهرات مماثله قدرت
عدد المشاركين فيها باكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
عامل هذه المره لم تدعو الى شن اضراب عام
بالموازاه مع المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه غير ان
قطاعات كالملاحه الجويه والنقل بالقطارات
وكذلك الطاقه تشهد اضطرابات بعد تمديد
الاضراب فيها كما ان الاضرابات الواسعه
حاله دون جمع الاف الاطنان من النفايات في
مدن فرنسيه عده
الازمه المتصاعده على الجبهتين السياسيه
والاجتماعيه لا يبدو انها اربكت خطط
الحكومه فهي طرف التعديل مصدرا لتمويل
نظام الضمان الاجتماعي احدى ركائز
الانموذج الاجتماعي الفرنسي
لا يبدو ان الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرو هو
الاخر قد عدل موقفه على وقع الاحتجاجات
الطاغيه على ولايته الثانيه
تمسك الرجل بتعديل قواعد التقاعد ورفض طلب
النقابات العماليه عقد لقاء مباشر معه
لكنه قال ان الحكومه ستبقى مستمعه بشان
هذا الاصلاح الذي يصفه بالضروري لم يسمع
احد حنقنه تقول الطبقه الوسطى وتلك التي
دونها في فرنسا
فبينما كان كثيرون يطالبون برفع الاجور
باغتتهم السلطات بمحاوله رفع سن التقاعد
فهل يفلح التحرك العمالي المعارض لتلك
الخطط في ابطالها او طرحها على الاستشاره
الشعبيه
زاد هؤلاء استياء لجوء الحكومه الى ماده
دستوريه تقضي بالتصويت جمله واحده على
مشروع القانون
بعد معركه اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار اقر
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي الذي يهيمن عليه
اليمين ماده رئيسيه في مشروع تعديل نظام
التقاعد
وتسرع الاغلبيه في المجلس الخطى لاقرار
الاصلاح كاملا قبل انقضاء المهله النهائيه
منتصف ليله الاحد اذا لم طارئ ما خطه
الحكومه فهي تتوقع اقرار البرلمان بمجلسيه
التعديل بحلول منتصف الشهر الحالي لكن
عليها قبل ذلك كله اجتياز نهايه اسبوع بدت
للفرنسيين حاسمه
ينظر الينا من باريس ستيفان وهو مدير قسم
السياسه والابحاث في معهد ابسو السيد
ستيفان السؤال الكبير الان في فرنسا الى
اين تتجه الامور بين اصرار الحكومه
والرئيس من جهه وبين اصرار المتظاهرين على
مطلبهم
نحن فعلا امام طريق مسدود حيث لا يريد احد
التراجع لم نشهد يوما اعتراض الفرنسيه الى
هذا الحد ضد مشروع قانون هناك عدد كبير من
الفرنسيين يرفضون هذا التعديل وفعلا
الحكومه تقف في مواجهه الراي العام ولكن
من جهه اخرى الفرنسيون يعتبرون انه بالرغم
من هذه المعارضه الشعبيه ان الحكومه
والرئيس سوف
يسراني على التصويت على هذا المشروع
وبالتالي طريق منسود لانه ليس هناك تراجع
من احد من الاطراف النقابات ترفض التخلي
عن هذا النضال والحكومه ترفض التخلي عن
هذا المشروع ولكن حتى لو اعترض الفرنسيون
فحركات
الاضراب والمظاهرات بدات تفقد زخمها فهذا
كله ي الاقتصاد ويعرقل البلاد اذا اليوم
لدينا وضع معقد بسبب التضخم وبالتالي
تزايد ايام الاضراب سوف يثقل كاهل الناس
اذا هذا هي الورقه التي تلعبها الحكومه
تراهن على ان يساهم الفرنسيون على ان
يلقوا السلاح من صحه القول ان يتوقفوا عن
الاعتراض على هذا المشروع وبالتالي الطريق
مسدود ولكن بالرغم من ذلك وهذا لمصلحه
الحكومه التي قبل نهايه الاسبوع سوف تمرر
هذا المشروع عندما تقود اكبر النقابات
العمريه العماليه في فرنسا هذه المظاهرات
هل مساله الرهان على الوقت للتراجع وارده
هذا غير مرجح صراحه يجب ان نضع انفسنا
امام الرئيس الفرنسي الذي يواجهه اعتراض
الفرنسيين ولكن اذا تراجع واذا سحب هذا
المشروع سوف يكون قد مونيا بهزيمه سياسيه
فاضيه وتكون قد انتهت التجربه المكرونيه
ان صحه وصفها وبالتالي يكون قد فشل في
محاولاتي لاصلاح فرنسا كما يقدم نفسه لن
يسحب هذا المشروع لانه سيحظى بالاغلبيه في
البرلمان الفرنسي حتى لو لم يكن الفرنسيون
راضيين حتى لو تم التصويت على هذا المشروع
واعتمد هذا الاصلاح فهذا سوف
يعرق
يلقي بظلاله على العلاقه بين الرئيس
والراي العام الفرنسي والشعب الفرنسي هل
تشبث الرئيس والحكومه بهذا القرار كما
قالوا بانه هناك ضروره لاتخاذ هذا الاصل
يعني
يحتاج او
كما يقال يعني يكافئ هذه المكافاه وهذه
المغامره او هذا المواجهه بينه وبين
الشارع
يريد ان يترك بصمته في تاريخ الفرنسي لانه
لا يمكنه ان يترشح لعهده ثالثه
ما يريده وما هو هواسه اعلان هو ان يترك
بصمه في التاريخ الفرنسي مفادها انه اصلح
النظام في فرنسا في عهده الاولى لم يحقق
الكثير بسبب جائحه كورونا والحد في
اوكرانيا وحركه السترات الصفراء والان هذه
فرصه الاخيره لكي يصلح البلاد حتى يذكره
التاريخ على انه حاول ان يدفع بالبلاد
قدما ويدخل اليها الحداثه وبالتالي انا لا
اتخيل انه سوف يسحب المشروع ولا يكون هو
بيده قد دمر اخر عشر سنوات من عمله شكرا
لك من
باريسو شكرا جزيلا لك
الى جورجيا حيث تتهم المعارضه الحزب
الحاكم بمسانده روسيا وعرقله انضمام
جورجيا للاتحاد الاوروبي بينما يرى الحزب
الحاكم ان جهات خارجيه تؤجج الاحتجاجات
الاستهدافه
ايليا سابا وبيكا طلاب جامعيون من اوائل
من انضم الى الاحتجاجات الاخيره في تبليسي
يقولون انهم يدافعون عن الديمقراطيه في
بلادهم ويعتبرون قانون تصنيف العملاء
الاجانب تهديدا لها
سنكافح ضد هذا القانون وكل قوانين الحزب
الحاكمي الموالي لروسيا
نريد الانضمام الى اوروبا فهي هويتنا
وخيارنا ويجب ان نحارب من اجل ذلك
سحب البرلمان قانون العملاء الاجانب لكن
التازم السياسيه لم ينتهي
فاحزاب المعارضه والمحتجون يرون في اداء
الحزب الحاكم مسانده لروسيا وتلكوا في
اتخاذ موقفا واضح من الحرب في اوكرانيا
واعاقه لمسار الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ان اوروبا والولايات المتحده ولدان في حرب
اوكرانيا وهذا هو تماما موقف بوتين
بالنسبه اليهم حلفاؤناهم اعدائهم الاتجاه
الذي ياخذوننا اليه يعيدنا الى التسعينيات
عندما كنا معزولين عن الغرب وتركنا وحدنا
في مواجهه روسيا
غير ان حزب الحلم الجورجي الحاكم ينفي اي
تعاطف مع روسيا ويشير الى ان تدخلات
خارجيه اججه الاحتجاجات لاقحام جورجيا في
الصراعي باوكرانيا
بحجه ان حزبنا موار لروسيا غير ناجحه وهي
مستمره منذ عقد تقريبا ولا شك في ان
المعارضه وبعض الاحزاب تقوم بذلك لكن
الشعب يعرف موقفنا جيدا وافعلنا تظهر
حتميه موقفنا بالانضمام الى الاتحاد
ويترقب لجورجي يونا بقلق ما ستؤول اليه
الامور في ظل تصاعد الاتهامات للحزب
الحاكم ومطالبه احزاب المعارضه والمحتجين
باصلاحات مختلفه ليست هذه المره الاولى
التي تعيش فيها جورجيا ازمه سياسيه جوهرها
بين الغرب وروسيا لكن هذه المره تبدو
الامور اكثر تعقيدا في ظل حرب اوكرانيا
والمواقف الروسيه والامريكيه والدوليه من
المظاهرات الاخيره هنا جوني طونيوس
الجزيره
احتجاجات ومظاهرات في جورجيا ومشروع قانون
مثير للجدل ثم تراجع عنه تطورات بدت
وكانها ليست شان يخص جورجيا وحدها السبب
هو الموقع الجغرافي اللافت لهذا البلد
جورجيا جمهوريه جبليه تقع على الساحل
الشرقي للبحر الاسود تحدها شمالا روسيا
كما نشاهد في الخريطه بما ذلك جمهوريه
الشيشان وجنوبا تقع ارمينيا
واذربيجان وتركيا البحر الاسود من الغرب
تعمل روسيا على دعم نفوذها في جورج الدوله
القوقازيه الصغيره المجاور لها وكذلك في
ارمينيا واذربيجان جنوب القوقاز الى
كازاخستان في اسيا الوسطى سبب القلق
الروسي الراغن ان طبعا هذا القلق من
الجانب الروسي ان الكريم يرى مخاطر
واستفزازات محتمله في اوسيتيا الجنوبيه
وكذلك
هم بالمناسبه اقليماني انفصاليان في
جورجيا تدعمهما روسيا بعد الاحتجاجات التي
خرجت في جورج اعتراضا على مشروع القانون
تطمح جورجيا الى الانضمام رسميا للاتحاد
الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي وهو اتجاه
اتخذ بعد ثوره الورود في العام 2003 التي
حملت الى السلطه ميخائيل سكشينلي المؤيد
للغرب وهو اليوم معارض ومسجون
ماذا في توقيت ما يحدث في جورجيا تخوض
موسكو حربا في اوكرانيا تعتبرها معركه
وجوديه مع الغرب حول مستقبل كل من روسيا
وكذلك الدول التابعه سابقا لفنك الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق وتلك التابعه لنفوذها منذ
عام
لكن ماذا في تفاصيل الازمه التي تعصف
بجورجيا هذه المره منذ ايام وما الذي دفع
بالولايات المتحده وبلدان اوروبيه وروسيا
بطبيعه الحال الى الدخول على خط هذه
الازمه هو مشروع قانون الاثار الكثيره من
الجدل
ينص المشروع على ان المنظمات غير الحكوميه
ووسائل الاعلام التي تتلقى اكثر من 20% من
تمويلها من الخارج ملزمه بالتسجيل على
انها وكالات نفوذ اجنبي تستخدم روسيا نصا
مشابها في السنوات الاخيره لمعاقبه
وملاحقه مئات الناشطين والمنتقدين
الاعلاميين للكرملين وهو ما دفع المعارضه
الجورجيه لاتهام الحكومه بانها مؤيده
لموسكو الحكومه دافعت عن مشروع القانون
واعتبرته ضروريا لزياده الشفافيه فيما
يتعلق بتمويل المنظمات غير الحكوميه ورفضت
مقالته بقانون روسيا يعود قانون الروسي
يعود لعام 2012
يوم الجمعه الماضي وبعد ايامنا الاحتجاجات
الغى البرلمان الجورجي مشروع القانون خلال
جلسه برلمانيه رفضه خلالها 35 نائبا من
اصل سته وثلاثين شاركوا في التصويت
اذا للبحث في هذا الملف وهذا الملف الجديد
ما يتعلق بجورجيا ينضم الينا من دبلن
البروفيسور
الاستاذ السياسه في كليه القانون والحوكمه
بجامعه والمحاضر في سياسه ما بعد الاتحاد
السوفيتي اهلا بك دكتور دونخه هل ما يجري
في جورجيا هو انعكاس لما يجري في اوكرانيا
وفي اي اتجاه
الجان في نزاعها مع ارمينيا في محاوله
منطقه نجاردني
كلما ضعفت روسيا طبعا تتاثر بقيه البلدان
لكن ما يحدث ليس له علاقه بشكل مباشر
باوكرانيا ما يحدث في جورجيا ان هناك
حكومه تريد ان تتشبث بالسلطه وهذا امر
معروف لكن
المعارضه الرئيسيه مقسمه في البرلمان
لكنها تحاول
الاظهار قوتها عبر منظمات المجتمعه المدني
لهذا السبب الحلم او اوضحت موقفها
والمجتمع المدني حرك الشارع بحركه
الاحتجاجات هذه في هذه الحاله الدخول
اطراف اخرى على خط ما يجري في جورجيا وهنا
اعني مباشره موسكو
واشنطن هل كيف سيؤثر على هذا المشهد وان
كان كما ذكرت ليس مرتبطا بالضروره بما
يجري في اوكرانيا
انني لا اعتقد ان روسيا هي في موقع حاليا
يتيح لها توسيع دائره نطاق صراعاتها اكثر
مما هي فيه الان لكن جورجيا هي جزء من
عمليه الشد والجذب على مدى قرنين من الزمن
كانت جورجيا جزء من الامبراطوريه الروسيه
ثم الاتحاد السوفيتي لكنها من جهه
قبلت فكره ان معظم الشعب الجورجي يرى
مستقبله في اوروبا وهذا في صميم ما رايناه
يحدث في الاسبوع الماضي الحكومه ملتزمه
ومتمسكه
بهذا الموضوع ولكن اوكرانيا
ومولدوفيا عندما
تقدمت بالطلب تم قبوله لكن طلب جورجيا لم
يقبل
وحكومه جورج على ماذا سنعطي الماضيه
سلكت سياسات وسلوكيات لا تتوائم مع
المتطلبات الاوروبيه الغربيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي والشعب يرى نفسه وكان حكومته
بالسياساتها ابعدته عن الاندماج الاوروبي
ولهذا السبب كان هناك هذه
شكرا لك واعتذر منك ادركنا الوقت
استاذ السياسه في كليه القانون والحوكمه
بجامعه المحاضر في سياسه ما بعد الاتحاد
السوفيتي
[موسيقى]
في ختام هذا الحصاد هذه الليله ناخذكم الى
اندونيسيا وقصتها مع البراكين نعم هذه
الباركيه تشاهدونها معي في هذه الصور هذا
الدخان وهذه الابخره المتصاعده من هذا
الجبل في وقت سابق اليوم صار بركان ميرابي
احد اكثر البراكين نشاطا في العالم مطلقا
سحابه ساخنه بارتفاع يصل الى سبعه
كيلومترات وقاذفا الدخان والرامات كما
نشاهد في هذه الصور تقول السلطات في بيان
انها ثماني قرى على الاقل قرب البركان
تاثرت بالرماد البركاني وتسبب اخر ثوران
كبير للبركان في مقتل اكثر من 300 شخص في
العام 2010 وفي اجلاء حوالي 280 الفا وكان
ذلك اعنف ثورا له منذ العام
1930 عندما اودى بحياه حوالي 1300 شخص
نحو 130 بركانا نشطا في هذا البلد في
اندونيسيا وهي ارخبيل يضم اكثر من سبعه
على عشره الف جزيره ويقع على حلقه النار
كما يوصف في المحيط الهادئ اندونيسيا في
حاله تاهب ودعواتنا لاهلها بالسلامه دمتم
بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]